Hello there, and welcome to cowboy hour with
Alex. Yeehaw. I asked my patrons which precon
they wanted me to look at from Outlaws at
Thunder Junction, and a plurality wanted to
see Grand Larceny. So in this video, I’m going
to look at that precon, and I’m going to ask
three questions—what is the deck trying to do,
how well is it doing that, and how could it be
improved to better accomplish that task? With that
framework set up, let’s talk about the commander.
Here we have Gonti, Canny Inquisitor. Gonti
reduces the cost of your stolen spells,
and thieves the top card of an opponent’s
library whenever you get through combat
damage on them. My first thought when I saw this
is that this card is almost identical to another
commander set card that saw a reprint last year,
in both effect and power level—Ramirez DePietro,
Pillager. They both exile opposing cards to play
whenever opponents are hit, they both give a way
to pay for part of the cost of stolen cards, and
for an extra mana and an extra color Gonti has the
benefits of not being restricted to pirates, being
able to play opposing lands, and being able to
spend mana of any type on stolen spells. Luckily,
I actually quite enjoy this design—I find the
design of stealing cards as a result of hitting
multiple opponents to be fun and encouraging of
dynamic gameplay. Theft as a general archetype
is fun in that it scales to table power level,
but where some theft decks go wrong is in making
theft the whole gameplan, and having absolutely
no plan for winning outside of yoinking opposing
bombs. This will be okay against opposing midrange
decks some of the time, but it will struggle if
you get unlucky or if you’re facing off against
decks that are more synergistic, which win through
cards working well together rather than powerful
individual cards. I like the design of Gonti and
Ramirez because conditioning a deck’s theft on
it dealing combat damage to one or more players is
kinda like bumpers on the side of a bowling alley.
It prevents deckbuilders from making the classic
blunder of forgetting a win plan, since the cards
needed to do the theft—creatures that aren’t being
blocked—are also a thing that will win games.
With that out of the way, let’s talk about
Gonti in particular. I’d classify Gonti as
a soft payoff—a payoff that is pretty easy to get
some value off of, but which scales only modestly
with additional inputs. The amount of cards stolen
per turn by Gonti caps at 3, and a 1 mana discount
on stolen spells is also pretty modest for a
five-mana commander, meaning that we’ll likely
be falling behind if we aren’t maxing out the
advantage we can from Gonti starting pretty
early in the game. For this reason, I expect some
amount of a Gonti deck to be made up of evasive
creatures that can get down to thieving not long
after Gonti has hit the board. It doesn’t need to
be a whole ton—one trigger for each opponent
means we’re not playing Edric or anything,
but if we’re not getting three triggers per turn a
decent amount of the time, we’re leaving advantage
on the table. Another possible choice with Gonti
would be running additional cards that steal,
but running too many of these effects might be a
bit of a trap—we only have so much mana to spend
on opposing cards. So these are going to be the
immediate two things I look at—a decent amount of
evasive creatures for getting Gonti triggers, and
maybe a modest number of other cards that steal.
Looking at the creature base of the deck, we do
see 18 creatures with flying or another form of
hard evasion. There are also a number of cards
that encourage dealing combat damage to a player,
a category which obviously includes
the commander as well. As a result,
this deck has a decently potent evasive
creatures gameplan, which it uses to
generate value off of the commander and other
cards. As expected, we can also see a small
suite of cards in the 99 which can steal
cards and reduce the cost of stolen cards,
and these will naturally lead the deck into a
late game plan of playing lots of opposing cards,
using theft in tandem with its evasive
creatures to bring the deck to victory.
So, that seems to be the plan. But how is the
deck doing with this gameplan? I’ll start with
what I like here. One of my biggest criticisms
of the Blame Game precon was that the manabase
was quite bad. [Insert clip of WotC please] So
did my pleading to Wizards of the Coast lead
to any improvement? Well, this deck’s manabase
is… honestly pretty good. The colorless utility
lands are capped at 2, and the deck runs
sets of temples, painlands, check lands,
and bad filters, as well as a spattering of other
dual lands, including two good filtering lands.
WotC seems to have made the choice to give this
precon a $30 manabase rather than give one or
two powerful cards to justify the precon
price, and I honestly fully support this.
New players need good lands a lot more than
they need a Trouble in Pairs. Now, that said,
there are places to improve with this manabase.
I’m going to be talking about one improvement a
bit later in this video, and I have a whole video
on building a manabase in the pipeline, but the
overall message I’m trying to get across here is
that this manabase is pretty good and you can pick
up and play with this deck without worrying too
much about getting color-screwed or mana-screwed.
Another thing I like is that this deck
has a decent amount of removal. The deck
has two creatures that bonk stuff when
they hit players, a couple board wipes,
and a handful of pieces of targeted removal.
It’s also running a couple counterspells,
though both are playing into the theft vibe
here and end up being a bit subpar as a result,
for reasons I’ll talk about a bit later.
In addition to this, the deck’s ramp suite
and value engines are decent enough, which
should allow the deck to keep on chugging
into the lategame and not run out of steam. The
deck’s ramp, draw, and interaction will also be
supplemented by cards stolen from opponents,
though I support the choice to have a decent
amount in to start with so that we’re not relying
too much on opponents to play the game. Okay,
so that’s the stuff I like. With that out of
the way, what do I dislike about this precon?
So, this deck reminds me of a lot of older precons
in terms of the cohesive-ness of its vision,
or lack thereof. There are two different gameplans
here—evasive creature beatdown, and theft—and
actually, my first impression when looking at
the deck was that they might play decently well
together. The commander is clearly trying to act
as a point of fusion here, and there are a number
of creatures that play into both the evasive
creature plan and the theft plan. So, what’s
the problem? Well, there are a few issues at play
here. One is that the deck isn’t running enough
evasive creatures, and the ones it does have cost
too much mana on average. I’d say the deck almost
always wants to have one or more evasive creatures
in play by the time it gets its commander out,
but the list only contains 12 evasive creatures
below 5 mana, which isn’t a very reliable count
for such a pivotal type of card. The deck could
be looking to develop some 5-7 mana beaters and
play the commander a bit later, but this requires
more ramp than the deck is currently running,
and also doesn’t utilize the commander as well.
Overall, the current suite of evasive creatures
just doesn’t work for me—this deck wants three
Gonti triggers a turn, and that’s just not going
to be consistently fulfilled by this selection.
Another issue is that there’s a lot of cards that
do some sort of stealing-oriented thing, but don’t
require paying mana to cast the cards. This might
seem normal at first blush, but there’s actually
basically no mechanical connection between these
cards and the theft theme as a whole. They’re
identical to a random midrange beater as far
as cohesion and synergy are concerned. This is
not to say that these cards are all bad—Thieving
Skydiver is a lovely card, Dazzling Sphinx
is a solid evasive creature, and the ninjas
are fun payoff for evasive creatures. What
it is to say, though, is that this deck is
effectively spending some number of card slots on
flavor—which isn’t an objectively wrong choice,
but for a mass-market playable-out-of-the-box
product, it’s certainly a choice.
I ran 30 playtests with the deck, and overall
it had some good curve-outs, usually either
landing quality 2 and 3 drops into the commander
or ramping into one of the deck’s bigger threats,
but it also had a lot of not-great curve-outs. In
15 of the 30 games the deck failed to curve-out in
a way that would allow it to meaningfully
launch into a gameplan by turn 5-6. This
failure can manifest a number of different ways,
but the most common ones were failing to spend
its mana on turns 2-4, playing out cards that
weren’t impactful, having disjointed card types,
and failing to gain enough mana to accomplish
the tasks that the deck’s draws might allow
for. The deck did occasionally miss land
drops and have awkward color situations,
though this definitely wasn’t one of the more
pressing issues, and it’s also likely fixable
with a bit more early filtering. Overall, I can
definitely see this deck feeling pretty great
with certain sets of draws, but a lot of rollouts
with this deck are kinda disjointed and awkward.
So, what could this deck do to improve? First
of all, I wanna talk about some cards I just
generally dislike. Cunning Rhetoric is a
mixture of a defense card and a theft card,
but it doesn’t actually accomplish either task.
Your opponents can choose not to send small-scale
attacks your way to prevent you from getting
value, but when they do want to attack you,
the downside of getting a single card exiled for
up to a full board of creatures attacking is just
not a deterring factor in the slightest.
Next up, Void Attendant. I get the vision,
and I love the idea of repurposing a forgotten
uncommon from 2015, but the card just isn’t
that useful here. This deck can’t do much with
tokens, has enough draw to not need a mana sink,
and doesn’t have enough instant speed plays to
make it useful as a mana banking option. Another
card I dislike is Mimeoplasm—this deck has no
mill of any kind and one singular card that
causes you to discard, making our boy Plasm
a pretty dead draw before the late game. Yet
another card I hate here is Stolen Goods—the
average nonland card in an EDH deck is like
3.5 mana, and so you’re getting less value than
the amount of mana you paid and what you get will
likely be unrelated to what you’re trying to do
at any given moment. Next up, redundant cards. I
strongly dislike Predators’ Hour—it does the same
thing that the command zone does, but without any
real upside other than a possible tokens plan.
I like Dream-Thief’s Bandana a bit better,
but it still compares very unfavorably to a
similar equipment such as Mask of Memory or Mask
of Riddles. Running either of these cards when the
deck doesn’t even have enough evasive creatures
to consistently get enough Gonti triggers each
turn feels wrong on a pretty fundamental level.
It’s at this point I should also jump back to the
two counterspells I mentioned earlier. Both cost
a lot of mana, and high-cost counterspells
with added bonuses do work—but mostly only
in draw-go style control decks. This is because
these decks will often run spells that further
their gameplan at instant speed, most often card
draw, and this allows them to counter a thing if
they need to but still have a way to spend that
mana on the end step before their turn if they
don’t end up countering anything. By contrast,
this deck runs very little at instant speed,
meaning that if it holds up 4 or 5 mana for a
counter spell, that’s just wasted mana if the
counterspell doesn’t get used, and this will
often incentivize players to counter something
largely irrelevant in order to not waste the
mana. Plasm Capture is also very symbol dense,
so I’d cut it for a lower-cost counterspell like
Negate. Smirking Spelljacker will stay in for now
despite my misgivings about its manacost, and
this is because it’s also a 3/3 creature with
flying, which means that countering something
irrelevant is still a mostly acceptable outcome.
With those initial cuts out of the way, I think
there are two possible paths forward for the deck,
and those two paths are: play more into the big
theft stuff by adding more ramp, or play more
into the combat damage element by adding evasive
creatures and evasion. Basically, take the two
things the deck is doing, and make it focus more
on one of those. I’m choosing the second one,
and that’s for two reasons. Firstly, I don’t
think Gonti should be thought of as a pure theft
commander—the requirement of hitting opponents is
already pushing the deck in a somewhat aggressive
direction, and spending too much deck space on
other theft cards and theft payoffs worsens the
deck’s ability to get in for combat damage and
get Gonti triggers. The other reason is this
deck’s alternative commander—Felix Five-Boots is a
fun card that is clearly pushing for a more combat
damage oriented version of things, so I choose to
take cues from that as well. I justify this here
because I personally would choose to cut quite
a lot of cards that fit into the theft theme,
and I could see that being a contentious choice.
Doc Aurlock? Just reducing the cost of stolen
cards isn’t good enough. Oblivion Sower? Doesn’t
do enough. Villainous Wealth? This deck isn’t
really a ramp deck, and playing Villainous Wealth
with a mana spend of less than 10 won’t be worth
it most of the time. Chaos Wand? Also funny and
also not good enough outside of a big mana deck.
Extract Brain is similarly awkward outside of a
ramp deck, because the ideal hit is a big bomb,
but you’ll be battling against time to
play it with a big enough X before your
opponent is able to play the hypothetical threat,
and you also might end up targeting a player
only to find nothing impactful in their hand.
What am I bringing in for these cards? The most
notable type of card I’m adding is what I’ll
call evasive utility beaters—creatures that are
low-cost and have both some sort of evasion and
some sort of benefit that smooths out the
deck’s gameplan. The first three of these
I’m adding are Malcolm Alluring Scoundrel,
Looter Il-Kor, and Suspicious Stowaway. The
package here is great—2 mana evasive creatures
that also offer looting on hit—and these will
help smooth out draws and filter away unneeded
cards. Siren Stormtamer is another solid add,
offering a bit of protection in addition to being
an evasive creature. Thousand-faced Shadow is
another utility 1 drop, and this has the benefit
of allowing us to slip through something like a
Silent-blade Oni on a crowded board, since the
token is unblockable due to being created after
the declare blockers phase. I’m also adding
a couple 3-4 cost utility beaters, with one
of these being Drana, Liberator of Malakir. This
card is going to help with the beatdown gameplan,
and the fact that it buffs everything else
before combat damage is a nice touch. Rankle,
Master of Pranks is another utility
beater that can offer a wide range
of use cases depending on what the deck
needs or what would set back opponents.
My final utility beater add is Kellan Inquisitive
Prodigy, a card that also adds a bit of ramp to
the deck. I don’t think this deck needs a lot
of ramp, but I think a gentle increase to the
amount of ramp isn’t a bad idea either. Another
addition I opted for is Wayward Swordtooth,
a solid beater that also allows for extra land
plays. I like extra land play cards in theft
decks, because they allow the deck to ramp using
opposing lands. I also added Mask of Riddles and
swapped out Darksteel Ingot Sonic Screwdriver
to increase the amount of evasion in the deck,
as being able to swing something like a Fallen
Shinobi or a Silent-Blade Oni through a crowded
board is quite nice. From there, my other nonland
additions were a couple counter spells and a
removal spell, just to give this deck a bit more
ability to deal with concerning things opponents
are doing. The deck wasn’t doing terrible on
this, but it has the deck space for a bit more
interaction due to the value it has in the command
zone, so I’m gonna give it that interaction.
Now, onto the manabase. As I said, this deck’s
manabase is pretty good, with the biggest issue
I note being that its check lands don’t have as
much support as I’d prefer. As a quick fix this,
I choose to swap out the temples for Dominaria
United typed lands. Ideally an incremental change
for the deck would be to swap these out for Karlov
Manor duals, but those are going for upwards of $5
apiece at the moment so they can wait if you’re
not trying to spend too much extra. I also wish
that Wizards would print enemy cycles of Tango
and cycle lands, as it’d be nice to have a bit of
upside to sweeten the deal of cutting temples. The
other change I made to the manabase was swapping
out a swamp and a forest for two more islands,
since we added several more cheap creatures in
blue. I could delve a lot deeper into building a
three-color manabase, but I won’t be doing that
in this video due to the aforementioned
acceptable-ness of this deck’s manabase.
Alright, those are my improvements. Overall, I
like this precon okay. If I was to be charitable,
I’d say that it was probably built with the intent
of allowing modification paths for both a zanier,
full-theft build and for the path I chose of
emphasizing combat damage and evasive creatures.
If I was to be uncharitable, I would say that
evasive creatures is really the only build of this
deck that actually works with Gonti, and that all
of the unsynergistic, goofy theft stuff is at best
an obstacle to throw newer players off the path
of making the deck actually decent, because who’s
gonna cut a Chaos Wand or a Villainous Wealth when
those cards are so fun? Whatever the case may be,
this precon reminds me of a lot of older ones
in its lack of focus, though its decent card
quality and solidly-built manabase will certainly
lead to it performing better than most of those.
Thanks for watching, and as always a big thanks
to my Patrons who allow making YouTube videos
to be my full-time job. That’s pretty
cool! You can also let me know in the
comments if you liked this, or if you agree
with my analysis of the deck. I tried to go
a bit more in depth on the improvements, as
I kinda blazed through them with Blame Game.